how are you feeling today
i'm feeling i'm feeling good i'm i'm i'm
pretty okay you know watching it back
was really hard
but
mistakes mistakes are miss takes you
know what i mean like you learn from
them take it's
take two you know what i mean and so
yeah that's all that's all i can garner
from this is is be like you made a lot
of mistakes but
there's always room for growth for
everybody so yeah that's awesome you
were such a light during the season and
you made everyone laugh including me as
a viewer
what helped you keep such a positive
spirit and like just making everyone
laugh in such a high pressure scenario
yeah so
if you watched my interviews pregame and
like i even talked about it a little bit
on the show
my heroes are
the kids at the children's hospital that
i would volunteer and work with
and i even said like they are always
happy
they're i'm so much more privileged than
them in the the body that i have in
physical health and so for them to go
through the trials and tribulations that
they do on a regular basis and and have
a smile on their face and have a good
attitude like like i have no reason to
be angry and i used to be really angry
all the time like i was raphael the
ninja turtle like i was i was always mad
and so
yeah it does kind of hurt though to go
out there and and and all my
confessionals like i never said a bad
thing about anybody and then to watch it
back and be like everybody just dogs on
me the whole time i'm like that sucks so
what are you gonna do though
i have to ask about the advantage when
shan saw it in your pants did you just
forget it was there
yeah i mean it was just
me being a bad survivor player you know
like it was
it was very much
me not being aware and that was probably
my biggest problem was that
my mind would always go to all these
different places i was always like
thinking of like what to do next and not
looking at what i'm doing right in this
moment like right now i'm walking up to
camp where's my extra post
sticking out my pants i remember the
moment where she said what's that
i literally have dreams of that moment
and i'm like i should have been like
toilet paper or something i don't know
it was just terrible it was terrible and
i
nobody i can blame but myself you know
so did you expect that reaction like it
almost seemed like she was grounding you
as you were her child or something
in the moment i was like that's i
thought it was fair in the moment i was
like i got caught with it i have to deal
with the repercussions you know like in
that survival like you deal with the
repercussions
um
what
made me a little bit perturbed is
they treated me so poorly when they
found out that i kid that from them like
they didn't even show you they treated
me so awfully i was like a pariah i was
a pariah out there
and then to come to find out that they
were lying to me anyway it's like i'm
like give me my extra vote back freaking
jerk
that's also another thing though it's
like i didn't want to work with shannon
ricard
but i had to i had no other choice
because genie and brad didn't want to
work with me so and that's my fault like
clearly my social game was
subpar if i couldn't get brad and
jeannie to flip on them so
i spoke with brad last week and he told
me that you were his number one at the
beginning
how did you feel seeing him leave
i
you know mixed back
because
brad is such a a good man
and that's why i bonded to him he's like
he's a just a good man you know what i
mean and
jeannie would disappear to look for the
idol and chan sarah and ricardo would
disappear to go strategize together and
me and brad are the only ones working on
the shelter and i saw that he was like
he respects hard work he respects
people with good manners so you see on
the show when i talk to brad i'm like
yes sir no sir you know like like always
showing that and always showing a good
work ethic like that was important to me
to show brown like i'm a military kid
like i grew up doing chores and so
brad was my number one we were eating
grubs together they didn't show they
didn't show but we i talked to brad
every day like 10 times a day every day
and
after sarah's vote out he didn't talk to
me at all so i knew he was with me like
he wouldn't he didn't want to talk to me
at all and so i i'm still confused why
because i saved brad at that first
tribal council
and then he works with the people
who i was saving him from to get me out
and i was like
it doesn't make any sense and i wanted
to flip it on ricard but they they
wanted me for some reason i i didn't get
it
maybe it has a little bit to do with
shan were you surprised that she knew
about brad's all of brad's advantages
and then she treated you that way
when she had all this information in her
pocket yeah i mean i mean you're
supposed to do that in the game of
survivor you're supposed to withhold
information from people because
information is the most powerful thing
you can have and so i didn't blame her
for withholding information i blamed her
for treating me so poorly
for lying to her and then like she was
lying to me the whole time
so but she's a great player like trick
is amazing i can't deny that so
and so
you couldn't get the ring on in last
night's episode
did you feel like that kind of sealed
your fate or did you have no idea that
you were going to be going home going
into tribal
i i definitely knew that if i didn't get
the ring that i was like
i mean if you watch the
the challenge back afterwards i'm
literally just laying their head down
because i'm like i'm going home
like because
i knew i was target target target every
single tribal council and i was like
this baby where my luck runs out and so
they blame me for that challenge loss
i don't see how it was my fault when i
was the only one who could land a ring
i guess that money shot they're like if
you wouldn't have said money it must
have gone on i don't know it's like i
can say whatever i want i'm the one
throwing the rings and you guys are just
watching
so
i don't know
do you hate ring toss now are you ever
gonna play it again no uh
i wish i could show you can i can i move
this yeah
so
like literally so long before survivor i
bought a banana rung like a rung that
holds bananas and i nailed it to my wall
right here
and i bought pool rings and literally
every day for
for months almost a year before survivor
because it got postponed postponed
because of kovit i would
throw those rings on that banana rung
and so losing that was just
losing the ring toss sucked i love ring
toss
that's amazing that is amazing um so
what was going through your head when
shan asked to hold your vote did you
think you're going to get it back and
you could use it again
i 100 thought chick was playing me for a
little bit right
because
they didn't show you but i even said
like are you trying to black widow me
right now
like i was like are you trying to refill
it's party shallow me and she's like no
i would never and she got like really
offended and i was like okay
and that
shannon is such a good player because
there's so much in that move
that people didn't see like
shan would pretend to be paranoid at
tribal council on purpose and i didn't
even realize it until she voted me out
you know what i mean if she would have
come to me
paranoid like out of nowhere on that day
that would have been a red flag
but she had set a precedent of being
paranoid so i was like
i just need to do whatever i can to calm
her down so brilliant play by her like
oh she's so good
what did you think of her song the song
she hums in her head so cool it's so
cool i'm like why didn't i think of that
like why did i not think to do that
and you'd
and i thought it was the looney tunes
theme song but
she was humming her theme song and i was
like this trick is crazy like
why is she humming
that's so cool though
did you have a song that kept playing in
your head while you were out there
gosh no
i work
i'm trying to think of like a theme song
i don't know
you say run by my hero academy like from
from my hero like that's it
but i lost everything so i didn't really
deserve a theme song
you still do come on
how important do you think an alliance
is to staying in survivor
alliances are crucial i mean
no one you you even saw with me you kind
of see that brad and jeannie are buy one
get one half off wherever brad goes
genie's going whether it makes sense or
not and then ricardo and
shanward duo and i was kind of like an
island unto myself so you'd think i'd be
the swing boat but no i was just on the
bottom straight up like everybody just
wanted me out and so alliances are so
crucial a reason why i couldn't flip it
on ricard
and shan
was because i had no one
the only person i had was me and myself
me and my extra vote you know and so
that was really it that was really all
that
i could do was suck up to shan because
brad and jeannie didn't want to flip it
on him
you're a super fan yeah
how was your experience aside from
obviously not the outcome you wanted did
it live up to everything that you
thought it would be as a super fan
it was everything i could ask for and
more you know i know a lot of fans don't
like
all the advantages and like that's
understandable because like you guys
like the pure purity of the game but for
me like i've always loved when survivor
introduced new twists like i thought
i thought going to that island was so
cool like getting to be the youngest
person out there and getting to go on
the trek on day two and getting an extra
vote
like that was what my survivor dream was
the only thing that could have made it
better was if i was xander and i got an
idol
and was just amazing at challenges like
that's the only thing i could ask for so
yeah
love survivor oh my gosh
and this was this is the hardest season
yet so what was the hardest part for you
you know a lot of people will say it was
the rise the lack of sleep i didn't care
about the rise i didn't care about
sleeping arrangements i didn't care if
it rained i just wanted to play the game
and so
the hardest part for me was
knowing
as a super fan like this is the optimal
move to make
and not being able to make it
and then going with the second
quote-unquote best move and
it being bad like doing it wrong i think
the hardest part is
watching myself make mistakes
try to correct from the mistakes and
make more mistakes